cette est rendue officielle hier le
collège des médecins retire les
restrictions sur la pilule abortive
une bonne nouvelle pour des médecins qui
le revendiquait il y avait d'ailleurs
une lettre ouverte en 300 médecins des
femmes pour la plupart qui avait demandé
la semaine dernière à ce que justement
les restrictions soient levés alors
l'une de ses continuateurs la médecin de
famille docteur geneviève bois élite
avec nous ce matin bonjour docteur bois
mon jeu alors je ne trompe pas le susdit
que pour vous c'est une très bonne
nouvelle ça veut dire que vos efforts
ont porté fruit finalement
oui donc que la nouvelle qui est très
bien accueillie hier chez les
signataires à qui j'ai pu parler une
deuxième barrière qui tombe après
l'annoncé la semaine dernière par le
collège que l'échographie ne serait plus
systématiquement obligatoire alors hier
on apprenait le par une infolettre
envoyé à tous les médecins du québec que
la formation spécifique qui était
uniquement le une obligation dans la
province du québec ne serait plus aussi
une obligation donc on vient de voir
deux grandes barrières augmenter le
nombre de prescripteurs pour la pilule
abortive et possiblement le donc à
l'accès à l'avortement québec qui
viennent de tomber depuis une semaine en
quoi cette réglementation là auparavant
était un frein pour pouvoir obtenir la
pilule abortive
d'une part aucun frais logistiques halle
pour un médecin une médecin qui ne s'est
pas nécessairement à quel point il va
offrir le service de façon fréquente
vous c'est quand même là au lieu d'aller
vers une formation en personne
obligatoire le pour pouvoir
potentiellement prescrire la pilule
abortive annoncé pas toujours d'avancer
quand est ce que le soin de nous est
demandé mais aussi d'un point de vue
plus philosophique il n'y avait pas de
raison scientifique de m rapport
l'avortement médical du restant de la
victime pour le restant de la médecine
les médecins sont les gens qui doivent
décider combien formation continue doit
faire ses tables de suivre leur code de
déontologie et donc en mettant une
obligation uniquement pour ce soin leur
aurait séparé l'avortement médical du
restant des soins de santé qui se ça
contribue pas à encourager les gens à
s'impliquer à prescrire la pilule
abortive ni à agde avant de l'avortement
moins tabou en fait ouais le collage
annonce également qu'il veut se pencher
il va avoir un groupe de travail en fait
là qui va se passer sur l'apport
possible d'autres professionnels par
rapport à la pilule abortive est ce que
vous vous croyez que par exemple des
infirmières ou des pharmaciens devraient
pouvoir l'a presque
ce qu'on voit dans le reste du canada
puis dans des juridictions cinar au
québec le sait que des sages femmes ou
des infirmières praticiennes offre
parfois des soins de santé reproductive
comme l'avortement médical pas de raison
que ça soit impossible au québec donc
j'espère que c'est une voie qui va être
explorées c'est quelque chose qui doit
être discuté le terrain avec les autres
professionnels concernés qui ne sont pas
régis par le collège donc en fait
pourrait commencer à prescrire sont
nécessairement l'aval du collège mais
c'est mieux évidemment si on travaille
ensemble donc ça pourrait aussi
augmenter l'accès de pas une façon c'est
sûr d'aller voir en pratique on connaît
déjà que ce soit un corner notre sage
femme ou notre médecin sacrés d'éolien
confiance donc ça pourrait être une
belle avenue je sais pas encore qui va
être sur le comité qui est ce qui va
être fait sur le comité donc ça sera à
voir comment ça se déroule ces travaux
là mais c'est certain qu'il faut essayer
d'augmenter l'accès aux deux méthodes
d'avortement réduire les embûches qui
sont en ce moment sur le chemin des
personnes qui cherchent un avortement
ouais on comprend que cette décision-là
du collège des médecins était un peu
précipité du moins que la réflexion a
été accéléré en raison de la décision de
la cour suprême aux états unis qui est
venu justement restreindre le droit à
l'avortement pour de nombreuses
américaine quels sont les barrières
encore à l'avortement au québec
donc il existe encore des nombreuses
barrières à l'avortement québec je
dirais que trois grandes catégories la
première et logistique c'est pas parce
qu'on a beaucoup de points de service il
y en a un qui ont un horaire peu
d'honneur rendez-vous à dans des délais
raisonnables à ses proches de chez nous
on peut aller donc certainement lieu
encore des enjeux de ce côté là en terme
d'accessibilité souvent les rendez vous
peuvent prendre une double parfois plus
de semaine même dans des grandes villes
donc c'est quelque chose sur lequel il
faut travailler sinon il ya un aspect
financier les femmes qui ont pas de
grandes cuves aller doivent payer la
procédure ou de médicaments et se faire
rembourser si elles sont suivies le dans
une autre province saison déjà une autre
assurance mais si c'est du dior
étrangères par exemple qui ont une
assurance privée ça sera pas payé
quelques pas de ram cube donc un enjeu
financier finalement il ya un enjeu de
l'information le beaucoup de centres
anti cheval qui sont décrits en suspens
entre ce qu'on appelle des centres de
crise qui donnent des informations
erronées sur l'avortement et qui tente
de décourager les personnes de
considérer cette option puisque c'est
très grave docteur geneviève bois c'est
vraiment un plaisir d'avoir pu vous
parler ce matin merci d'avoir pu
clarifier tout ça avec nous je vous
souhaite une excellente journée bonne
journée au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]